vowing to get the southern border under
control but better act quickly while the
administration works to deport thousands
of mostly haitian migrants from a
squalid camp in del rio texas more than
20 000 more haitians are reportedly
waiting in colombia to make their way
into the united states texas governor
greg abbott was down in del rio and
unloaded on the president
the body administration has been
promoting and allowing open border
policies failure to enforce laws that
exist in the united states leads to
chaos
and chaos leads to inhumanity
the body administration
is a man-made disaster
of inhumanity of epic proportions it
must end it must end immediately and the
media and democrats being accused of
misrepresenting the facts for pushing a
narrative that border patrol agents were
whipping migrants watch
what i saw depicted about
those individuals on horseback treating
human beings the way they were is
horrible i fully support what is
happening right now which is a thorough
investigation i was not aware that whips
people had that kind of equipment on
them that they could use on humans there
is obviously systematic racism at play
here it does smack of a bygone era
of slavery
aided by reports of people being beaten
whether with a riding crop or the rains
border patrol is pushing back saying
agents and horse reigns uh use horse
reigns they're not whips i also i want
to point this out here's um secretary
marcus who yesterday defended the border
patrol
today he had changed his tune why watch
him
images have come out of border patrol
agents with communication immigrants so
my question to you do you think that's a
humane way to treat migrants you are
assuming facts
that have not yet been determined to
ensure control
of the horse long reins are used but we
are going to investigate the facts to
ensure uh that the situation is as we
understand it to be and if it's anything
different we will respond accordingly
any mistreatment or abuse of a migrant
is unacceptable we are very troubled by
what we have seen
and
a lot more to come on that but the
investigation didn't happen overnight
and yet he changed his opinion he has
gotten a phone call greg this whole
thing is
bad not just the whole made-up thing
about the whip but uh the situation is
bad but they are and there is a
humanitarian crisis yes order as well
but i don't care about the humanity
humanitarian crisis until i can find an
angle that i like and that's what you
just saw with these dumb hacks that you
just saw on that montage
these networks these people had no
interest in this story until they could
create an acceptable villain in law
enforcement they didn't give two poops
and i said poop i was going to say the
other one about the 12 000 refugees that
were there but oh they discover a
twitter image in and they're
doom-scrolling and it looks like a whip
and so they go full covington right
chris cuomo yamiki april all these other
bozos who pretend to be journalists then
pretend to have a story do you know that
if the democrats and the media had cared
enough about this crisis from the time
that we started covering it months ago
and then weeks ago with this this actual
story would not exist it wouldn't be
necessary for guys to be on horses to
help control the crowd so they're put
would i say they're pulling a covington
i mean this
they could not use the striking video
that has been coming from fox from the
drones or from the helicopters because
you cannot manipulate that image those
images are real it tells the whole story
but you can take one disturbing image
right one disturbing image and you can
turn it in and manufacture a narrative
that is to your liking these lazy hacks
ignored the stark footage that had been
coming out and then suddenly they are
outraged we must reject these fools
they're disgusting and they don't care
well they they don't care about the fact
that we are a sovereign nation we have
the right to protect the border they
aren't taking a story that they're
saying to you don't believe your lying
eyes you've got a guy on a horse border
patrol riding western with split rains
you use a rain to get the horse to move
this way or that way if you're in a
situation where there are people or
another horse that's very close it's a
quick way to move the horse it's got
nothing to do with the people on the
ground it's you maneuvering your horse
and the fact that they would turn that
into them doing something like whipping
the illegals is outrageous it is
outrageous so the border patrol agents
were attacked by the vice president of
the united states and now the department
of homeland security before an
investigation if they really need to do
an investigation um could they
could they claim that they have a
hostile workplace geraldo
first of all i have to say that
what is this the cisco kid
you know these are
migrants
fleeing a desperate situation
these aren't escaping inmates and this
this behavior this macho man behavior is
absolutely unacceptable can you accuse
anyone of macho behavior that's been
your career for 50 years i'm not i think
that you may be right about that but
i
i
appreciate our frontline
uniform services they've got a tough job
there's a crisis at the border of joe
biden's making i i concede that
absolutely we have to do something trump
did it better i concede that but when
you
have that happening that shows an
attitude that is absolutely unacceptable
what are they doing wrong when is what
are they doing how would you like it if
it was your ancestor coming across the
damn rio grande and the guy on uh you
know there's a guy in a horse trying to
enjoy
and uh you could make a distinction
between
he wasn't whipping it wasn't i was a
slave for 12 years whatever that movie
was but there's a big rain and big
horses and he's trying to intimidate and
terrorize interpreting
you're interpreting an image personally
if it was you it wouldn't be your
interpretation but he's not breaking the
law
i'm with greg reject the fools right
yeah so i mean i hear you have kamala
harris saying we need to treat them as
human beings uh the mistreatment america
said the mistreatment of migrants is
unacceptable i get that but where in the
hell these people been when little girls
are being sold into sex slavery little
girls are dying in the desert their
parents are dying in the desert drugs
are flowing into the country this has
created mass human health
hold on a second hold on that's his job
to prevent it that's what i said
we don't have it but i watched a video
before i came on the show where actually
the migrants were pushing women in front
of them into the into the horses
themselves and they're like the border
patrol was like what are you doing
pushing women into us what kind of
people are you so geraldo you can't take
a small video and categories border
patrol who has been doing yeoman's work
on the humanitarian side on the border
and and castigate all of them
republi i mean democrats need to step up
and go listen we've created this mess we
have we have a humanitarian crisis
coming across mexico into our border
leave the border patrol alone and if
you're going to get outraged don't get
outraged at this video get outraged when
the hordes are taking place
i am i all of it outrages me shawn
there's no doubt about it this is a
crisis joe biden's kindness has created
this cruel kindness kindness has created
cruelty no but we still have to bend
over backward this is america this is a
place where we don't have horses chasing
we do have horses
of
in america they do this in times square
at last call i've been there i've been
there with the horses come out today you
probably have they're coming
oh there you go
we'll get to that in my block the other
thing is sean that kamala harris
the press secretary said she was working
on the root causes
where where is that well it's a great
point where are the root causes are they
in the northern triangle the root cause
is now in haiti are the root causes all
over the country yeah the real causes
weren't actually that's a good point and
the report that she provided the root
causes or i want to come to america
the root cause is everybody wants to
live in america education medication
housing welfare and you know what
disability i want all that maybe i want
to work there are 150 000 haitians in
new york city alone they are the best
neighbors they are business people
my orcas should be fired i mean do you
sit out here and say my strategy is that
i'm going to tell people not to come to
the border as opposed to shutting down
the border judge shut it down do what
trump did he needs somebody send people
back um but the homeland security our
homeless our homeland security is
devastated by this kind of leadership